>>> DURING THE JANUARY 6TH
ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL, THERE
WERE TRUMP BANNERS AND
CONFEDERATE FLAGS, THERE'S ALSO
CHRISTIAN IMAGERY, THE WOODEN
CROSS, PEOPLE IN PRAYER, THE
JESUS SAVES SLOGAN.
MUCH OF THE HOUSE JANUARY 6TH'S
COMMITTEE'S FOCUS SO FAR HAS
BEEN ON RIGHT WING EXTREMIST
GROUPS.
THERE ARE AMERICANS WHO HAVE
ADOPTED CHRISTIAN NATIONALISM
WHO WERE THERE AS WELL.
SAMUEL PERRY IS AN ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR AT UNIVERSITY OF
OKLAHOMA AND COAUTHOR OF "THE
FLAG AND CROSS WHITE CHRISTIAN
NATIONALISM AND THE THREAT TO
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY," PROFESSOR,
GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
PART OF THE REASON WE'RE HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION IS BECAUSE
CONGRESSWOMAN MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE SAID THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
SHOULD BECOME THE CHRISTIAN
NATIONALIST PARTY.
WE'LL GET TO THAT IN A MOMENT.
BUT FIRST OF ALL, WHAT IS IT,
WHAT IS CHRISTIAN NATIONALISM?
>> CHRISTIAN NATIONALISM IS AN
IDEOLOGY THAT SEEKS TO IDEALIZE
AND ADVOCATE FOR A FUSION OF
AMERICAN CIVIC LIFE WITH A VERY
PARTICULAR KIND OF CHRISTIANITY
AND WHEN WE SAY CHRISTIANITY, WE
DON'T MEAN PEOPLE WHO LOVE JESUS
WHO HAVE TRIED TO LIVE
CHRIST-LIKE LIVES.
CHRISTIANITY IS CODE WORK FOR
PEOPLE LIKE US THAT ARE
CONSERVATIVE NATURAL BORN
CITIZENS WHO THINK LIKE US AND
LOOK LIKE US.
CHRISTIAN NATIONALISM SEEKS TO
FUSE AND INSTITUTIONALIZE THAT
KIND OF CHRISTIANITY WITH
AMERICAN POLICIES AND SYMBOLS
AND FOUNDING MYTHS AND OUR KIND
OF DEEP STORY.
>> WHEN THE BOOK SAYS WHITE
CHRISTIAN NATIONALISM, IS IT
ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY BASED ON
RACE, EXPLAIN THAT ELEMENT?
>> SURE.
WE FIND IN ALL OF OUR STUDIES
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT THESE
THINGS WITH NATIONAL SURVEY
DATA.
WE FIND THAT WHEN WHITE
AMERICANS HEAR THE LANGUAGE OF
CHRISTIAN NATIONALISM, WHEN THEY
HEAR ABOUT CHRISTIAN HERITAGE
AND CHRISTIAN VALUES THEY TEND
TO THINK WITH NOSTALGIA IN A
TIME WHERE PEOPLE LIKE US, THE
HAD CULTURAL AND POLITICAL
INFLUENCE, WHEN
AFRICAN-AMERICANS HEAR CHRISTIAN
NATIONALISM LANGUAGE, THEY THINK
MORE ASPIRATIONALLY, WE NEVER
LIVED UP TO OUR OWN VALUES.
WE CALL WHITE CHRISTIAN
NATIONALISM THIS IDEOLOGY THAT
SEEKS TO TAKE BACK AMERICA FOR
ALL, LACK OF A BETTER PHRASING,
ALL WHITE ETHNICALLY WHITE,
RACIALLY WHITE, TRADITIONAL
CONSERVATIVE AMERICANS.
PEOPLE LIKE US, PEOPLE LIKE
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE THINKS.
>> THERE ARE SOME EVEN IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WHO WOULD SAY
THAT SOME OF CONGRESSWOMAN
GREENE'S VIEWS ARE FRINGE.
THIS IS NOT, THIS IS CENTRAL,
THIS IS VERY MAINSTREAM.
>> YES, WE FIND IN SURVEY AFTER
SURVEY THAT THE KINDS OF BELIEFS
THAT MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE
AFFIRMS THAT WE WOULD BE PROUD
CHRISTIAN NATIONALISTS, THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY OUGHT TO BE THE
PARTY OF CHRISTIAN NATIONALISM.
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE MAY SEEM
FRINGE IN THE FACT THAT SHE'S
OUTSPOKEN AND TENANT ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS A COMMON IDEOLOGY,
AMERICANS BELIEVE AMERICA WAS
FOUND ON BIBLICAL PRINCIPLES,
CHRISTIANITY MADE US PROSPEROUS
AS A NATION.
WE OUGHT TO RETURN TO IT AND
INSTITUTIONALIZE CHRISTIANITY AS
OUR IDENTITY, AND MAKE POLICY IN
LIGHT OF IT, AND PRIVILEGE
CHRISTIANITY IN THE PUBLIC
SQUARE ABOVE OTHER RELIGIONS AND
QUESTION WE DON'T HAVE TO GET
EQUAL TIME AND RECOGNIZE OTHER
RELIGIONS AS MUCH AS
CHRISTIANITY.
>> OBVIOUSLY A NATURAL SEGUE
INTO WHY THE SECOND HALF OF THE
TITLE IS THE THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY.
HOW DO YOU, THEN, CONFRONT IT?
BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE AS
ENCOMPASSING AS THE WHITE
CHRISTIAN NATIONALIST IDENTITY
IS THAT IT'S NOT JUST
CONFRONTING RELIGION, IT'S
CONFRONTING PRIVILEGE.
IT'S CONFRONTING ONE'S VIEW OF
ONE'S SELF.
HOW DO YOU CONFRONT SOMETHING
LIKE THAT?
>> RIGHT.
AND YOU SAID IT EXACTLY RIGHT.
I THINK THIS IS AN IDEOLOGY THAT
IS US VERSUS THEM.
IT IS NOT ABOUT MAXIMIZING SPACE
FOR EVERYBODY ELSE WHO DOES NOT
CELEBRATE DIVERSITY IN ANY KIND
OF FORM, AND IT REALLY TAKES THE
IDEA THAT THIS NATION IS FOR
PEOPLE LIKE US WHOM WE OUGHT TO
HAVE PRIMARY INFLUENCE, AND IT
IS FUNDAMENTALLY ANTIDEMOCRATIC
IN THAT REGARD.
IT IS NOT FOR VOTER ACCESS.
IT IS VERY MUCH AGAINST
MAXIMIZING DEMOCRATIC
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERYBODY ELSE.
SO HOW DO WE CONFRONT IT.
WE HAVE TO RETURN TO OUR
DEMOCRATIC PRINCIPLES, OUR IDEA
THAT THIS IS A SOCIETY THAT
CELEBRATES LEGAL EQUALITY.
AND ACCESS TO THE VOTE.
THAT WE WILL NOT PRIVILEGE ONE
RELIGIOUS GROUP OVER THE OTHER.
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ESTABLISHED
RELIGIONS IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT IS A FUNDAMENTALLY
UN-AMERICAN IDEA, AND SO I THINK
IT REQUIRES, THOSE OF US WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS WHITE
CHRISTIAN NATIONALIST MOVEMENT
TO LINK ARMS, TO UNITE WITH ONE
ANOTHER AND BOTH AS THOSE OF US
WHO ARE PEOPLE OF FAITH, THOSE
OF US WHO ARE NOT PEOPLE OF
FAITH BUT ARE AT THE SAME TIME
VERY WORRIED ABOUT THIS
IDEOLOGY.
YOU HAVE TO UNITE AND SAY THIS
IS NOT WHO WE ARE AS AMERICANS,
AND THIS IS NOT WHAT WE'RE
ABOUT.
THAT INCLUDES REPUBLICANS AS
WELL AS DEMOCRATS.
>> AND YOU GENUINELY THINK IN
THIS POLITICAL LANDSCAPE THAT
THAT WOULD BE IMPACTFUL?
>> I THINK THAT'S THE ONLY
CHOICE THAT WE HAVE IS TO SPEAK
TRUTH TO THIS KIND OF MOVEMENT,
TO SAY, YOU KNOW, THIS MAY NOT
BE FRINGE IN THE SENSE THAT NOT
A LOT OF PEOPLE HOLD IT.
I'M NOT TALKING NECESSARILY
ABOUT THE MAJORITY OF AMERICANS
WHO ARE WHITE CHRISTIAN
NATIONALISTS.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT.
I'M SAYING THAT THE VERY VOCAL
AND INFLUENTIAL GROUP OF PEOPLE
BECOMING MORE RADICALIZED AND
MILITANT, SAYING WE CAN PUSH OUR
AGENDA AND THIS IS THE TIME, AND
THEY MOBILIZE THE BASE WITH THE
ANGRY AND FEARFUL RHETORIC, IT
IS TO SPEAK BACK TO THEM AND SAY
THIS IS UN-AMERICAN, THIS IS NOT
WHAT CONSERVATIVES ARE ABOUT.
THIS IS NOT WHAT REPUBLICANS ARE
ABOUT.
I HOPE THEY BELIEVE THAT.
I HOPE THEY AFFIRM THAT THIS IS
A NATION WHERE RELIGIOUS LIBERTY
AND RELIGIOUS DIVERSITY AND
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DIVERSITY ARE
CELEBRATED, VALUED, WE WANT
THOSE THINGS TO BE OUR IDEALS,
AND SO I THINK IT REQUIRES US TO
LINK ARMS AND TO I THINK UNITE